hi there Steve Kaufman here I want to do
a second video about learning Spanish
and I'm gonna normally I don't normally
I try to have three videos a week I try
to keep it regular and I have been doing
these foreign language ie not English
language videos once a week followed by
a video where I talk about learning that
language and tomorrow hopefully I'll
have time to do a video in German and
I'll follow that a couple of days later
with a video about learning German and
in the future do on in Italian and
Swedish maybe but I wanted to sneak in
another one about learning Spanish
because of two questions that I received
from my viewers one person said quote
you Steve said that learning Spanish is
easy it is consistent and regular but
not easy and I think that's an important
point learning languages is not easy
every language has its difficulties
Spanish is consistent and its spelling I
think it has fewer exceptions in English
in many ways it's a more regular more
consistent language and it's certainly
easier in my mind for a native speaker
of English for example to learn than
Russian because the grammar is easier
and there is a lot of common vocabulary
but it's not easy and let's make no
mistake here you know it's easy to get
to a point where you can say a few
things you know ooh not that we have a
port for it's very easy to get to that
initial stage where you actually if
people speak slowly enough you actually
understand some things that they're
saying and you can actually say some
things that takes a few months however
to get to where you can read and enjoy
and watch movies and fully partake of
the culture and converse with people
that's a long road and it's not easy so
I wanted to make that point so you know
commit yourself to doing things
you're going to enjoy doing because it's
a long road but it's a rewarding road
for any language and in this case for
Spanish the second question I received
or comment was from a Spanish speaker
who goes by the name [ __ ] breed and he
sort of took exception to the fact or he
claimed that he was very disappointed
that my presentation of the reasons for
learning Spanish were so superficial
you know why does Spain or other Latin
American countries for that matter why
do they have to be identified with music
and color and holidays when really this
Hispanic culture is much more profound
than that and that I should have made
reference to because so I should have
made reference to a la Umbra el alhambra
in granada or you know the pilgrim road
to Santiago de Compostela okay
and then he implied well you probably
aren't aware of those or words that
effect one should make assumptions about
people I refer to those things that I
remembered very vividly I remembered
hitchhiking into Valente on seeing the
colors in the fields green and orange
and I should say by the way that I the
first book that I read in Spanish was La
Baraka which is a medium length book by
Oscar Bunyan about farmers in the valley
area and then I went there I've been to
a lumber I've been to Cordova Sevilla
I've seen la mezquita I could have
mentioned those things but I talked
about a meal that I had in Marbella
because it was a wonderful occasion
smelling the dama de noche de Jasmine
which only smells at night very fragrant
eating this fish that was wrapped in
salt under a starlit sky I mean it's a
very vivid memory it was also my 50th
birthday these are things that I
remember I don't think it's to denigrate
Spanish culture to talk about things
those things that left a very vivid
impression with me but I have been to
San Sebastian I was you know at the
fiestas de San Fermin in Pamplona in
1970 1964-65
and run with the Bulls because I didn't
want to get gored but I was partying at
the bars with all the friendly people
and uno dinero lost eight abraao tres de
Marco cuatro dari etc um I have been to
through Galicia I have been obviously
the Barcelona bull go Salamanca Segovia
Leone I mean countless places little
towns in you know carthoris for example
I mean I can't even remember all the
places I've been to and I've eaten the
food he said why didn't you talk about
like after Oh Mia yeah I mean they're
same things that I like in Spanish food
and things that I like less I like the
lighter tapas more the seafood tapas
that you get in Barcelona or in San
Sebastian whereas down south I've found
very often that tapas are into the
potato mayonnaise breaded deep-fried
stuff which I don't quite enjoy as much
but yeah it's it's fun and some of the
best meals have the simple roadside
restaurants where for 10 euros you get
the nice soup and treta and and a glass
of wine I could have talked about those
things too so I don't have a superficial
attitude toward Spanish in fact I give
this assumption that I know nothing
about Spain I mean I decided to trot out
all the books to go look for the books
that I've got here you know I've got you
know here we have what la vie de la
feria de Torres which is of course the
Middle Ages Miguel de Unamuno
- la guerra which I haven't read all of
I've got a number of books about history
because I like history and because
history is a big issue in Spain history
and and nationalism because that's a big
issue there la irrationally odd not you
know lista by Eduardo Alvarez puga and a
more interesting book than this because
this is more like party line but was
this one one quarries - whose members
name exactly is a Basque writer who
wrote this book called el bosque
imaginary au which talks about all of
the myths of origin in Europe generally
and of course it's a particular issue in
Spain with the Basques and so forth and
so on
a similar book to that when I was in
Mexico I discovered a writer called
Pablo Escalante ensemble and
this particular book is Carl area de
nuestro patrimonio historical igloo
Torah which is a collection of essays
about how Mexicans perceive themselves
their identity with the different
strains the the you know the native the
Spanish the Cleo do as and how these
things evolved over time I'll be another
book by him which was similar to this
but entirely written by him what have I
got here
here is land real Akali academia de la
historia Espania como nación can
remember that spin a wall in story
d'espagne
calderón De La Barca Vargas Llosa venti
cuentos de pano Americanos Esteghlal
Entei Gabriel Garcia Marquez here's
another history historia de espana
Fernando Garcia de corps Tasha I mean
Arturo Petra Burrill take a votre Baga
Trafalgar again when I read books like
this or Camilo josé cela Nobel Prize
winner there's a lot of words that I
don't know I prefer to read them on link
we have a number of historical novels on
link prick Cal dos Trafalgar and Academy
several audio like LibriVox plus the
text so that I can actually save the
words that I don't know because if I
read a book on history I know all the
words mostly but if I read a novel
there's more words that I don't know and
I like to study them on link
so anyway I'm not going to go through
all these here we have for example and
of course I do like Carlos Ruiz
cellphone by the way a cool Libre
complained that you know Spanish
literature isn't appreciated or Hispanic
literature isn't appreciated but there
been a number of Nobel Prize winners
from Latin America and Spain and even
and popular writers who aren't
considered you know Nobel Prize category
writers but you know carlos ruiz zafon
is translated into many languages he's
away on day
and her Arabic here equally laughter on
Fortuna is very interesting about the
history of Chile even though it's not
you know Nobel Prize category type of
thing I've also read books of course we
have Don Quixote which I've we have at
link and I've gone through parts of it
there I've read the whole thing and the
books in English you know Empire how
Spain became a world power and then
three books about this wonderful period
and these are books in English about the
wonderful period when when the culture
in in certainly the southern part of
Spain was more advanced than the culture
of you know Europe and the Dark Ages and
and have read a lot about how the
learning of ancient Greece and even of
the Middle East and India and so forth
were preserved by these Arabs and Jews
and that even the Visigoths would go to
Toledo to learn from the Jews primarily
who were transcribing all of these works
of philosophy and medicine and so forth
own so yeah I forgotten a lot but I have
read and I enjoy reading about Spain
Spanish culture Latin American culture
mostly in Spanish when I can cope and in
English and and these are this is
perhaps a small example of the world
that awaits those of you who want to get
into Spanish and and get and who enjoy
reading I also wanted to do another
video about learning Spanish because one
thing that cool libri says is you know
those hispanic culture is you know
flowered all over the world and Oceania
Asia Africans over which is not really
true anymore today I don't think many
people in the Philippines speak Spanish
the Filipinos that I have met don't
speak Spanish they might know three
words they might have a Spanish sounding
name that can't speak Spanish in Africa
either I think there's one is it
Equatorial Guinea or somewhere that
speak Spanish
however Portuguese and French are big in
Africa so if you look at Spanish as sort
of a flagship the door into the Romance
languages then I
think Spanish could become sort of a
second lingua franca alongside English
as a language that people would use to
communicate with like non-spanish
speakers communicating with non-spanish
speakers because if you count the
significant sort of number of people in
Africa who speak Portuguese and French
there's about 800 million speakers of
Romance languages in the world and so
rather than try to do something like
Esperanto which might be a little easier
to learn but which has very few speakers
and which is still very much influenced
by Latin and certainly by by European
languages
maybe his Spanish could be a
international language if we want to get
away from the sort of cultural dominance
of English you know there are other
candidates Arabic perhaps but my
understanding is that that the different
forms of Arabic are almost as different
from each other as Italian is from
Portuguese or French so and of course
therefore it's it's it's a small and a
smaller number of people who speak
Arabic Turkish the same way I don't know
but I'm wondering whether between the
weekers and the Uzbek sand the Turks
whether there isn't
in fact just as much of a difference as
there is in the different Romance
languages as in terms of the Slavic
languages and Russian is used by non
Russian speakers as a means of
communication as a lingua franca but if
I look at my experience with Czech while
a grammatical structure is very similar
in fact only about 50% of the vocabulary
is identifiable as as similar to Russian
words whereas with the Romance languages
we're looking at 80 percent similarity
between all of the main Romance
languages so Spanish not only is this
wonderfully rich world and I don't know
if I've convinced my friend cooley breed
to be a little more indulgent of me when
I make a 10-minute superficial video
trying to cover a lot
ground but not only is this Hispanic
cultural world rewarding of itself but I
I think that there is a possibility that
Spanish could become a genuine lingua
franca I see that as a bigger
possibility than China or Chinese rather
because Chinese is typically only spoken
by people who are communicating with
Chinese speakers okay there you go two
in a row on about learning Spain and now
I will get off the subject thank you for
listening bye for now